- Good morning Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe.
And I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve
all the major problems of the world.
I started the Believe Life
series to try to focus
on other topics, not just
related to entrepreneurship,
but useful skills, ideas and strategies
to help you live a better life.
So today we're going to
talk about how you can
detect a lie.
- Everybody lies.
- And as I was, guys, as
you're listening, if you hear
something that really inspires you,
please put it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it, so other people
can be inspired as well.
And when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself, as well.
Enjoy.
- Lying has evolutionary
value to us as species.
Researchers have long known
that the more intelligent
the species, the larger the
neocortex, the more likely
it is to be deceptive.
Now you might remember Koko.
Does anybody here
remember Koko the Gorilla,
who was taught sign language.
Koko was taught to
communicate vie sign language.
Here's Koko with her
kitten, sort of cute, little
fluffy pet kitten.
Koko once blamed her pet
kitten for ripping a sink
out of the wall.
(laughter)
We're hard-wired to become
leaders of the pack.
It starts really, really early.
How early?
Well, babies will fake a cry, pause,
wait to see who's coming and
then go right back to crying.
(laughter)
One-year-olds learn concealment.
Two-year-olds bluff.
Five-year-olds lie outright.
They manipulate via flattery.
Nine-year-olds, masters of the cover-up.
By the time you enter
college, you're going to lie
to your Mom in one out of
every five interactions.
By the time we enter this work world,
and we're breadwinners, we enter a world
that is just cluttered with
spam, fake digital friends,
partisan media, ingenious
identity thieves,
world class Ponzi schemers,
a deception epidemic.
In short, what one author
calls a post-truth society.
It's been very confusing
for a long time now.
What do you do?
- So let's start with the first thing,
the one that everyone wants to know,
which is what is the body
language that indicates lying?
Now unfortunately, there
really isn't one thing
that is going to, 100% of the time,
tell you someone's lying.
When you're looking to detect lying,
in terms of body language,
what you're looking for
are tells of stress with
regards to a particular
subject or topic.
And what that means is that
reading stress in the body
is actually much easier than
reading deception, right?
Stress comes through in
a lot of different ways
and you can see it in pacifying behaviors.
So that might be rubbing of the arm.
If they're sitting, you can
see people rub their leg.
You'll see people start
to touch right here,
that's a pacifying behavior.
And quite a few people chew on
their lip, cross their arms,
purse their lips, give you one of those.
All of these things create
a lowered, like trying to
calm yourself down, response.
And we do that in response to stress.
Now there's one thing that is classic
when people feel stressed,
and it's called blocking.
That means putting
anything between themselves
and the thing that is causing them stress.
So the classic lying example of blocking,
would be this, blocking the mouth,
could be covering the eyes, or
it could be an object, right?
Right at the time you're
asking them if they're lying,
they got to whip their phone
out, or they simply move
something in between you
and them on the desk.
Blocking is very common.
- So what I'm going to do,
is I'm going to show you
two patterns of deception.
And then we're going to look
at the hot spots and see
if we can find them ourselves.
We're going to start with speech.
- I want you to listen to me.
I'm going to say this again.
I did not have sexual
relations with that woman,
Miss Lewinsky.
I never told anybody to lie,
not a single time, never.
These allegations are false,
and I need to go back to
work for the American people.
Thank you.
- Okay, what were the telltale signs?
Well, first we heard what's
know as a non-contracted denial.
Studies show that people
who are overdetermined
in their denial will resort to formal,
rather than informal language.
We also heard distancing
language, that woman.
We know that liars will
unconsciously distance themselves
from their subject using
language as their tool.
Now, if Bill Clinton had said,
well, to tell you the truth,
or Richard Nixon's
favorite, in all candor,
it would have been a dead
giveaway for any lie spotter
that knows qualifying
language, as it's called,
qualifying language like
that further discredits
the subject.
Now, if he had repeated the
question in its entirety,
or if he had peppered his account with
a little too much detail,
and we're all really
glad he didn't do that,
he would have further discredited himself.
Freud had it right.
Freud said, look, there's
much more to it than speech.
No mortal can keep a secret.
If his lips are silent, he
chatters with his fingertips.
And we all do it.
No matter how powerful
you are, we all chatter
with our fingertips.
I'm going to show you
Dominique Strauss-Kahn
with Obama, who's chattering
with his fingertips.
(laughter)
Now, this brings us to our next pattern,
which is body language.
With body language,
here's what you got to do.
You really got to just throw
your assumptions out the door.
Let the science temper your
knowledge a little bit,
because we think liars
fidget all the time.
Well guess what?
They're known to freeze their upper bodies
when they're lying.
We think liars won't look you in the eyes.
Well guess what?
They look you in the
eyes a little too much,
just to compensate for that myth.
We think warmth and smiles
convey honesty, sincerity.
But a trained lie spotter
can spot a fake smile
a mile away.
Can you all spot the fake smile here?
You can consciously contract
the muscles in your cheeks,
but the real smile's in the eyes.
The crow's feet of the eyes,
they cannot be consciously contracted,
especially if you overdid the Botox.
Don't overdo the Botox, nobody
will think you're honest.
Clark Freshman is a law
professor who runs a firm
that trains lawyers and negotiators on
proper lie detection techniques.
He says that while
there's no surefire method
for detecting liars, there
are some advanced methods
they employ during questioning.
The unanticipated question
approach, for example,
is useful in cases where
you suspect someone may be
trying to cover something up.
This is based on the idea that
people in these situations
will often fabricate
stories without considering
all of the details.
So if someone commits a
crime, but their alibi says
they were at a restaurant
when it happened,
ask them questions that
they wouldn't expect,
like where was the
restaurant's bathroom located.
A person who's telling the truth
will have no problem
answering these details,
but a liar may struggle.
- Did you every steal
anything valued at more than
10, 25 dollars?
- No.
- Are you basically a dishonest person?
- Basically, a dishonest person?
(sighs)
- [Reporter] This polygraph
examiner, and retired FBI agent,
doesn't need a machine to pinpoint a liar.
- The eyes are a window to the soul.
You can see right through them.
- What do they expect from me?
That's a good question.
- [Reporter] Take a close
look at this guy's eyes.
Before Jason answers, he
looks up to the right.
- Looking up to the right means
you're making up something.
You're visually picturing
something that's never happened,
you know, that's a lie.
- [Reporter] Up to the left,
you're remembering something.
Only problem, it's the
opposite for lefties,
like Jason, so he's telling the truth.
Shifty eyes could also
indicate dishonesty.
- The moment they complete that lie,
they look right back at me,
because they're trying to see
whether I'm buying what they're selling.
- [Noah Zandan] Liars
typically explain events
in simple terms since our brains struggle
to build a complex lie.
Judgment and evaluation are complex things
for our brains to compute.
As a U.S. President
once famously insisted,
I did not have sexual
relations with that women.
And finally, even though liars
keep descriptions simple,
they tend to use longer
and more convoluted
sentence structure,
inserting unnecessary words
and irrelevant, but
factual sounding details,
in order to pad the lie.
Another president confronted
with a scandal proclaimed,
I can say categorically
that this investigation
indicates that no one on
the White House staff,
no one in this administration
presently employed
was involved in this
very bizarre incident.
Let's apply linguistic analysis
to some famous examples.
Take seven-time Tour de
France winner Lance Armstrong.
When comparing a 2005 interview
in which he had denied
taking performance enhancing drugs,
to a 2013 interview in
which he admitted it,
his use of personal pronouns
increased by nearly 3/4.
Note the contrast between
the following two quotes.
First, okay, you know, a guy in a French,
in a Parisian laboratory,
opens up your sample,
you know, John-Francis so
and so, and he tests it,
and then you get a phone
call from a newspaper
that says we found you to be
positive six times for EPO.
Second, I lost myself in all of that.
I'm sure there would be
other people that couldn't
handle it, but I certainly
couldn't handle it,
and I was used to controlling
everything in my life.
I controlled every outcome in my life.
In his denial, Armstrong
described a hypothetical situation
focused on someone else, removing himself
from the situation entirely.
In his admission, he owns his statements,
delving into his personal
emotions and motivations.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know what did you think?
Did you enjoy this video?
Did you learn something new?
Are you going to apply
this somehow to your life
or your business?
Is there a liar that you want to check out
and see if they're
telling the truth or not?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Joshua Rodriquez
from The Josh Speaks.
Thank you so much, Josh.
You're picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word,
and making that collab video with me
on your YouTube channel.
I really, really, really
appreciate the support,
and I hope you're enjoying the book.
- That's why I feel so honored to be able
to directly pass this video along to Evan,
so that he can share his
ideas on what it means
to live a life of purpose.
- So thank you guys again for watching.
I hope you have an amazing day.
Continue to believe in
whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.